great so we're here at devoxx 2013 we're
back and we have the angular guys Igor
and myshko welcome back thank you guys
were very popular last year think you
did even better this year you you were
all over the place you had a university
session three hours which will be online
and I heard good things about it how you
manage this three hours you had a code
lab which was a kind of full yeah lots
all my both awesome and you're just back
for me what you think the future of
angular will be session so you liking
the conference so far it's very good and
we always like the looks it's great to
be here well thing you had kind of a
hockey stick thing around Denmark's not
sure this is weird giving the dev acts
all the credit okay great so let's step
back for a second angular for anybody
you know that's been living under a rock
for the past couple years now I guess
what are we talking about we're talking
about framework for building client-side
web applications with HTML and
JavaScript CSS we focus on developer
productivity and combining all these new
technologies web technologies into
something that is really pleasurable
tues and it's also scalable and testable
so that you can build big applications
or small applications depending on what
you nee suppose word compliant awesome
so we're done we're talking MVC type of
framework we're talking data binding you
would say work quickly about that sure
data binding it's just a way from
getting the data from the heap memory
objects into the DOM and what backwards
so back back so that these are interacts
with the Dom through the input fields
etc we have to the memory response
directives scopes are their major
important concepts and I think the
reckless is unique because it's
something that
unique to us nobody else has this
particular thing of the idea is
extending the vocabulary of HTML
dependency injection one of you
mentioned that that's important the
dependency injection is just a way of
assembling all the objects and wiring
the application together which is great
because you don't need to do it by hand
and also makes the testability story
much better so in a year that you've had
that I think tremendous success what are
the interesting or surprising things
you've seen people do with angular that
has it been taken and used in unusual
places is it exactly as we had expect
all the time we keep on being surprising
about being keep on being surprised
about things people do with angular like
putting it in a car put in the car
seeing all kinds of visual things like
drawing diagrams that in a declaratory
like taking text and translating that
into diagram we seen slides gayness
games mobile applications that about
apps on iphone so here here DevOps the
actual the thing on the screen yes
screen is actually built with angular
yes so it's really a little plainer yeah
when we start with angular we really
meant it to be a way for building
enterprise enterprise applications but
people have taken it in very different
directions and it's surprising to see
what they can do with angular what you
mentioned in one of the session was that
you felt really well about the fact that
people actually building stuff they
weren't able to build before or not in
the same with the same productivity so
you could actually get something done in
a weekend whereas before it was like you
know this whole scam folding and
dragging library
right this I mentioned it before but it
really it's really nice when I talk to
people and they say hey I was able to
build this app that otherwise I wouldn't
exist went for angular and I feel really
good about it because I feel like this
applications can really change the way
people interact and how they have they
do things and how technology can make
lives better so um let's see you talked
about there's been a number of you think
so first of all angular 1 dot to it was
really finally finally time for dogs
thank you very much I'm not sure if it's
related okay it was pretty close and we
were heading for the also like yeah it's
time just kind of close that box driven
to go here we go so animations who wants
to talk about yes animations are also I
think something that we're very proud of
it's a very unique take on animations
yeah I think most frameworks just give
you a bunch of api's to use and we kind
of stood back and said you know how
could the animations look like if this
was just designed from scratch how can
we do it all declarative and so on and
so we really focused on just making
css-based animations just work out of
the box so if you want to add animations
as simple just adding whole bunch of CSS
animation code don't use too much of it
though not too many I mean animations
you you don't want to overdo it they
don't want to overdo it but you you want
to make it easy for people right so that
you want to have a subtle animation that
helps in getting the point across Orlin
just animation for animation psych right
it's not just for being pretty there
there's a purpose is UX concerns with it
do you want to talk about improve their
messages i think that's that's an
important one I mean a day to day
improvement that right so this is one of
the things that bothered me personally
because when I see people struggle with
their applications when they don't know
what is happening and they get free
unhelpful error messages it's not a good
spot to be in because not only the
application is not working but now
you're getting some information that is
not helpful in getting you from
this bad place so we did with angular's
we identified all of the RMS error all
the places where we throw our exceptions
from and we gave them unique identifiers
and give them very descriptive error
messages and also link them to
documentation page where with this error
message is described in a much larger
scope and describes the situations where
there has happened but as we were adding
these error messages we were quickly
realizing that we're adding bytes during
your JS and that's never a good thing
for client-side the code like you want
to keep the payload small so one thing
that we came up with was hey I was just
strip all this error messages from the
minified far a file but make it possible
to reconstitute the error messages on
this on the server just by clicking on a
link if you had the need to debug
something production so they'll give you
the possibility of debugging things in
production have you had the need as well
as smaller payload button develop any
good pull error messages and everything
is the way it should be the way you
expect it so speaking of development
what is the typical developer
environment for somebody that's using
angular do you what do you see out there
or do you recommend anything um I don't
think need to comment anything maybe
people see you sublime from VI to Emacs
do you know the standard stuff eclipse
is probably one of the nice things about
storing I persecutor prescriptive than
that in that sense but there is a real
for a couple of IDs that are actually
building it in I've like NetBeans I've
seen something from jboss was it I don't
know about Jay bones but Webster
knowledge a wheres Webster has a decent
support flying judges NetBeans working
hard on that and stuff but from the the
whole workflow would I'm happy about is
how angular encourages the tester in
development and developers actually take
for this advice and use test Randolph
and technique to build their
applications tools like karma really
helping with that and I'm just glad to
see that in practice so let's talk about
the future so one question I think you
guys get quite often is well stands our
standards are showing are there are
things like web cam photos how does that
you know influence the roadmap and what
you guys are doing with angular there's
a clash with what you've done already oh
so we actually talked about in our
future of angular talk and how we would
like to be on top of it and how web web
components is specifically the observed
part shadow shadow Dom was physically
shadow DOM is helping us making that
happen object observers in other area da
mutation observers and so on so the all
the dirty checking that you're doing
today is something that would go away
yes with optic observe and it's it's a
standard we helped right so yeah you
kind you've influenced it fair to say
yes the other thing you talked about was
how you like for developers to be able
to use parts of angular without kind of
dragging the whole thing so maybe just a
fancy injection for right so I
personally believe that modular ization
will be key component of the web
developing or the whole web ecosystem in
the future and this is what we would
like to take to our hearts and break
angular into smaller pieces each focused
on one particular task for example that
you mentioned the dependency injection
there is no reason why depends injection
needs to be built into angular we can
just extract it create a separate
library out of it and then use it in
angular but you can also use it without
angular in node.js application or some
other application or anywhere good any
other things you find important in terms
of the things you the feedback you've
gotten that you've taken and then do you
think you will influence the future of
angular um so one of the things that we
would like to do more is is get more of
the community feedback on things we are
doing um what's a good channel for that
definitely follow on twitter and google+
feeds on we're gonna be sharing some of
the proposals for the future versions of
angular and things that we wanted
and we would like community to help us
with by providing feedback on these
proposals and help us with reviews and
stuff like that okay so we're def Hawks
one of the big announcements here was
dart wonder oh I hear there's an
intersection with a regular you got a
bedroom with what happened there so we
would like you to have a choice in which
language you want to use and in
JavaScript you have a coffee script
answer I know all these are semantically
coolant to JavaScript so you can just
use them angularjs out of the box with
them but don't lisa is semantically a
little different and so we actually made
a port of angular on top of dart and
it's actually used internally at Google
so it's there's real apps running on it
I supposed to just hypothetical right
introduction at Google yeah yesterday so
Google currently we run both the dart
applications and JavaScript occasions so
because one thing that we see is that
language is such a sensitive topic among
developers like there are people who
have different backgrounds have
different preferences and you can't just
tell them you know this is the only
thing that you can use and it really is
up to the project after the team to pick
whatever they feel comfortable and
productive in and use the technology and
angular now gives them an option to go
either with dart or JavaScript great so
what should people go to find out what's
available today one there too and the
future obviously their website
angular.js org yep angular just a dork
and Twitter it's at angularjs and
google+ plus angularjs you guys are
having a conference soon I hear an
angular conference yep we have really
awesome community if we haven't
mentioned
and some of the members of the community
are throw in angularjs conference which
we are taking part in and this will be
take place in January Excel mid-january
and we will look really looking forward
to looking forward to that one thank you
guys we feel the best for the future and
now thanks for watching